Nửa rất thần nội bất ngờ khi thấy tổng thống hàn Quốc liJ miang công phương nhân
gừa giả hộ gơm vừa bắt tay với trảo thân thiện.
Tối hai bà tháng tư, tổng thống hàn Quốc liJ miang và phương nhân đi giạo quan hộ gơm
thu hút sự chú ý của đông đảo người dân và su khách, ông quý vẻ với tay trảo
bắt tay rau liệu với người dân và gấm hàn nội về đêm.
Tổng thống và phương nhân cũng vẻ mô kém thủy tạc để chia trò những người đi cùng.
Chức đó, hai người đã thử thức phở hàn nội trên phố đình liệt một trả nghiệp âm thực đặc trưng của thủ đồ.
Tổng thống hàn Quốc liJ miang sống hi hai tuổi, tương la Luo Siu và bắt đầu thăm ra chính trường từ năm 2019.
Ông cùng phương nhân thăm Việt Nam từ ngày 2 mốt đến 2 tư tháng tư, theo lời mời của tổng bị thư,
chủ tịch nước tổ lâm và phương nhân, nay là lần đầu tiên ông đến Việt Nam kể từ khi nhập trước tháng 6 năm 2020.